So, now the second thing to
know about humans, all right?
Human vision.
Humans are much more sensitive to
changes in what's referred to as
luminance, how bright something is than
they are sensitive to what color it is.
Now here's an example.
Now this example may work better or
worse depending upon how
your monitor is set.
So if you're not seeing
the illusion I'm about to show you,
play with your monitor.
Here's two images with text on them,
and in the top,
the background and the text are now, now
I'm going to have to change the color of
the pens, they're the same color, but
they're the different brightness.
Okay, different,
the technical term is luminance.
All right?
And probably all of you have
no problem seeing that it
says text in color without intensity
differences, blah, blah, blah, fine.
On the bottom, actually on the Mac
monitor, I can hardly read it.
On this monitor, I can read it
just fine because it depends upon
how each monitor, and
we're going to talk about monitors and
gamuts in a little bit,
how they show it.
But you could have adjusted
the color of the text in there so
that the color became almost,
what's called isoilluminant.
All right?
So the same amount of luminance, okay,
but different color so you just
basically take the, the cyan there and
just make it brighter or darker.
Don't change its, what we're going to
learn is called the hue, the color, and
you can make it go away, right?
So the bottom line is that
the human system is much
better at dealing with
differences in luminance.
So these phenomena, trike,
tri-stimulus color theory,
difference in luminescence, this has
been luminescence, has been known for
a very long time,
since the very early 1900s.
So starting in the 1920s, people
started doing some what are called
psycho-physics experiments
by psycho-physicists,
because who else would do psycho-physics
besides psycho-physicists?
Of basically showing people
different kinds of stimuli and
asking them what they see.